Speaker 1: Let's get back to the phones.
We take calls every Friday through the David
Pakman show discord, which you can find at
David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's hear from folks like, oh, I don't know.
How about James from Southern California?
James, welcome.
Speaker 4: Thank you very much.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
James.
Speaker 4: I'm first of all, thank you so
much for everything you've done over the years.
Thank you.
I wanted to ask your opinion on something.
What do you think the reality is of us eliminating
the Electoral College system and what would
be the path to that if it is a reality?
Speaker 1: I see it as an almost impossibility
through constitutional amendment.
This would be one way to change the Electoral
College.
It would be to actually have a constitutional
convention and change the way that it functions.
I see that as almost an impossibility.
The more likely scenario is something called
the National Popular Vote Interstate Compact.
The way this works is individual states can
design.
They can decide to assign their electoral
votes however they want.
Normally what states do is they say whoever
wins our state gets the electoral votes.
But states can say instead we are going to
give our electoral votes to whoever wins the
national popular vote.
So you could have a state like, for example,
Pennsylvania, say, in the future we're not
going to pay attention to whether Trump or
Biden win Pennsylvania.
We're going to pay attention to whether Trump
or Biden get more votes nationally.
And that's who will get Pennsylvania's electoral
votes.
Does that make sense, James, how that would
work?
Speaker 4: Yes, it does.
So it sounds like we pretty much if we want
to achieve this, we'd have to start rallying
on the state level.
Speaker 1: And the thing is, a bunch of states
have already signed up for this.
And, of course, for it to go into force, you
need enough states to do it such that their
electoral votes would be more than the 270
that one needs to become president.
But the problem is we're getting we've got
a lot of the blue states, some red states
or at least purple states are going to need
to come aboard.
And so that's the that's the challenge right
now.
But I see that as a way, more likely way to
get to a national popular vote than a constitutional
amendment.
Speaker 4: Sounds good.
At least in some reality.
They're pulling it off.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's not an impossibility, but it's also,
you know, this is not everyone's top priority,
I think it's fair to say.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
And that's.
That's the problem.
Yeah.
The long shot people aren't pushing for it.
We've got all these important short term things
to deal with.
Speaker 2: Exactly.
Speaker 4: Just falls by the wayside.
Well, thank you so much for your time, David.
I appreciate.
Speaker 1: It.
All right.
My pleasure.
There is James from Southern California making
a number of important declarations.